we have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David P I am going to play
a voicemail for you today. It is very short.
It's only 15 seconds long. This is either
one of our most uninformed callers ever or
an absolutely genius, satirical voice actor.
This, I think is related to recent conversations
about how educated versus uneducated white
voters vote in American elections. Take a
listen to this. You be the judge, uh, most
ignorant caller ever, or brilliant satirical
voice actor.
Oh, hi. Are you legal headed? A little sucker.
Just [inaudible] that's why people ain't educated.
Like you dumped suckers. You think you are
educated. This is racial discrimination. Maybe
we ought to send you back to Poland.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So I would think it's real except send me
back to Poland. I don't know where that came
from. So, uh, I dunno. You tell me. Let me
know either by replying, if you're watching
on or shoot me a tweet at di Pacman. Was that
real or was that satire? On today's bonus
show? X, Massachusetts governor Deval Patrick
is reportedly exploring a late entry into
the 2020 democratic primary. Now you will
remember, some of you will remember that Deval
Patrick has been a good friend to the David
Pakman show. I've interviewed him a couple
of times, despite the fact that he would always
call me Mark a a not David. That's okay. He
busy guy. Um, he has been pretty good in terms
of making himself available to the David Pakman
show when he was governor. And he is, um,
an interesting potential entrant with some
pretty status quo, a corporatist stuff in
his background, including being the lawyer
for Coca-Cola.
So we will talk about that. On today's bonus
show, we will talk about Amazon launching
a new grocery store as an alternative to whole
foods, but hold on. Amazon bought whole foods.
Now they're going to compete with whole foods.
Don't worry, uh, I'll explain it all on the
bonus show and a viral video, a black man
handcuff canned, cuffed for eating a sandwich
at a train station. Officials are now apologizing
for what was a really cringy interaction on
the, on the behalf of the police officer.
I will mention we will discuss all of those
stories and much, much more on today's bonus
show. Two ways to get access to the bonus
show. Number one, become a member. Go to www.joinpacman.com
click the red sign up button. Takes under
a minute. You'll be in on the bonus show.
Second option, go to patrion.com/david Pakman
show become a patron at at least the $5 a
month level. You will also get instant access
to that world famous bonus show hosted by
me Monday through Thursday, hosted by producer
Pat on Fridays last Friday. Or maybe the one
before. Producer Pat had a story about his
pants getting stolen. How could he [inaudible]
pants get stolen right off of his body? Well,
maybe it didn't go down exactly that way.
You can find out on the bonus show. I will
speak to you then in just a few short months.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].